hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
autumn 2015 edition in this edition are
articles on the cleaner Essex group work
to reduce the risk of flooding halloween
at the old house in rochford wild woods
and autumn fruits 50 shades of pee out
and about and forthcoming events and
this much more but we'll start with the
latest from wallasey Island the UK
government and the European Commission
have now officially opened jubilee marsh
marking the completion of the first
phase of the wallasey Ireland wild coast
project the amazing landscape has been
dramatically changed and improved
through boatloads of Crossrail earth
coming in from London to create lagoons
and banks for wildlife officials from
the European Union attended as the plan
is to use wallasey as a flagship project
where business and environmental
interests work together and encourage
similar developments worldwide wildlife
and bird enthusiasts Bill Oddie also
attended having travelled from his
London home to rupture by train and said
I had to come and see this for myself
it's a hugely significant project here
and once it bears in and nature takes
its course it will be wonderful and I
will come back again I wanna see the
project aims to combat the threats from
climate change in coastal flooding by
recreating the ancient wetland landscape
of mud flats and salt marsh lagoons and
pasture it will also help to compensate
for the loss of such title habitats
elsewhere in England although the
reserve is planned to be in development
until around 2025 anyone is welcome to
come along and view the progress as each
phase comes to life and the marshland
naturally regenerates the currency wall
access across the all fleets marsh trail
seawall is a wonderful place to come to
relax and enjoy taking in the sea air
and over the coming years the scheme
will create a varied wetland landscape
with more than 9
miles of new and improved access routes
and eventually a range of visitors
facilities and for updates on which
birds to watch out for and a map of
water sea island go to ww rspb a UK
halloween 2015 halloween seems to be one
of those things like marmite that people
either love or loathe if you love it
it's a great opportunity to dress up
carve your pumpkin decorate your home in
a ghoulish way meet up with friends and
family and get out there
trick-or-treating on All Hallows Eve
31st of October for those of you who
have children there are some good safety
tips that can be found on the poster
entitled are you a too smart trick or
treater this is available on ww2 smart
co uk / halloween essex police will be
out and about making sure everyone has a
good time without crossing the line so
be sure not to upset your neighbors by
behaving badly if you see a sign for no
trick or treaters don't knock on the
door sadly each year a small minority
have thrown eggs this can damage
paintwork and anyone found doing it will
be dealt with as causing antisocial
behavior and criminal damage if you
loathe it and don't want any
trick-or-treaters to come to your door
you can print off a sorry no trick or
treaters poster from ww2 smart co uk /
halloween or you can pick up one from
rayleigh police station rochford council
offices south street rochford and civic
sweet rayleigh or your local library if
you have suffered an egging wash it off
as soon as possible to prevent it
causing any damage if you're concerned
about any behavior near your home you
can call 101 to report it remember the
vast majority of children out and about
don't cause any problems and are just
seeking a treat most will be accompanied
by adults shopkeepers are being asked to
restrict
sale of eggs and flour to children and
young people in the week running up to
Halloween in a bid to reduce the damage
caused to property posters will be
distributed the week before for traders
to display in their windows this year
we'll be running a local poster
competition with schools so if you'd
like to take part why not design a
poster on the theme trick or treat let's
stay safe there is a competition for
children under the age of 11 if you wish
to enter this competition pick up a copy
of Rochford district matters for your
entry form the competition closes on the
6th of November the old house a gem in
the crown of Rochford district the old
house in Rockford was built in 1270
seated on South Street it's a real gem
in the district's crown and a must-see
for everyone the main hall was the first
part of the house to be built and is
more than 700 years old built of a
timber frame with wattle and daub panels
the house really was the height of
luxury in medieval England the panels
were made from a mixture of mud done
reeds and rushes all gathered from the
nearby river Roach and was plastered
with a mixture of goat hair and lime
with the wood supplied from hollywood's
the whole family would have lived in the
hall along with the servants and even
the animals in the winter months a fire
would burn in the center of the room
which would be used for cooking heating
and lighting it would have been lined
with tiles angled at forty five degrees
this was to cause an under draft to keep
the fire burning logs would have been
piled in a crisscross formation with the
smoke escaping from a small hole in the
roof in 1290 an extension wing was added
to the north side of the hall with the
south wing being added a hundred years
after that the main hall was still the
principal area but the extra wings
housed the Masters bedroom
Jones and a buttery in 1550 a chimney
stack was added to replace the fire in
the main hall at this time chimney
stacks were a mark of status this one
demonstrates a very high standing being
one of the most prestigious in the
country in the 1700's the upper floors
were added allowing the servants to have
their own living quarters in the south
wing rochford district council bought
the building in 1982 and using
traditional methods managed to restore
the house to its original glory using as
much of the original materials as
possible there was even a cauldron of
handmade lime wash in the garden area
which was used to paint the outside
walls here's a few interesting facts
about the old house when it was built
Henry the third the great great grandson
of william the conqueror was king of
england and it was still at least 200
years until the discovery of america
some of the old beams were too damaged
to be left in the structure but luckily
we discovered that a wharf at malden was
being knocked on the timber from the
wharf is believed to be over a hundred
years old and that was used after many
hundreds of years of subsidence the
house was sinking badly particularly in
the north wing the floor had to be
raised eight inches on the right and ten
inches on the left is still not level
but the builders couldn't raise the
floor anymore without putting the rest
of the building out about a hundred
years ago the tie beam in the Masters
bedroom broke in half and it was
repaired using an iron girder which was
bound to the beam untied with a piece of
rope the repair was still in place in
1983 it was repaired after that by
inserting carbon-fiber rods into the
beam adding an epoxy resin and easing it
together it now has the same
strength as it first had in 1291 of the
visitors to the hall wrote very
memorable fascinating I had no idea the
building was here and I've lived in
rochford all my life now if you'd like
to book to go and visit the old house
please ring Vanessa Conroy in
communications on 0 1 702 318 0 14 you
can email her Vanessa Conroy at Rochford
dot-gov dot uk' the love essex campaign
the cleaner essex group recently
launched a follow-up to last year's
highly successful love essex campaign to
continue the battle against litter
across local authority areas in essex
with local authorities budgets depleting
every year the demand and pressure on
services such as street cleansing rises
this year's love essex campaign
continues the fight against litter by
asking people to bend their litter
responsibly for six weeks in august and
sep tember councils businesses
volunteers community groups and
enforcement teams did their bit to
encourage litterers to change their
behavior buses and bus shelters petrol
pumps posters and fast food packaging
carried messages to target different
audiences to show that binning your
litter is the smart classy and cool
thing to do and above all a pretty easy
thing to do several new retail giants
took part in the campaign this year with
coca-cola the co-operative and Costa
Coffee joining the stand against litter
last year all 14 Essex local authorities
and Essex County Council joined forces
with rp2 media and 75 businesses from
McDonald's KFC and Domino's to raise
awareness of littering and the risks of
fines of those who offend resulting in a
forty-one percent drop in fast food
litter the campaign and its approach was
highly acclaimed by keep britain tidy
and in 2015 one the diamond jubilee
partnership award recycling keep it
clean draw
I and loose there are many items that
can be placed into your recycling bin
and some of these will originally have
contained food all items put in your
recycling bin should be clean a quick
rinse will do items that have leftover
food on them or liquid in them can ruin
quality of other recycling put in your
bin this can then ruin the rest of
recycling in the lorries and at the
recycling facility items that are
covered with leftover food and drink
cannot be recycled it's also important
that your recycling is kept dry and your
bin lid is kept closed please keep place
all items in your bin dry please ensure
no wet paper or cardboard goes in the
bin and that all your cans and bottles
are empty first if you're recycling gets
wet the paper and cardboard will become
soggy and glass will stick to the wet
paper and cardboard meaning these items
can't be recycled also during the
process at the recycling facility wet
paper and cardboard will stick to the
machinery and clog up the system clean
dry items must be placed loose into the
bin plastic carrier bags or sacks are
not permitted in the recyclables bins
and your bin may be left unconnected if
these are placed in here when the
materials arrive at the recycling
facility anything in bags or sex is
discarded and not recycled as the
contents can't be seen so it can't be
confirmed if these are definitely the
correct materials in addition plastic
bags and sacks cannot themselves be
recycled dog fouling as we know not all
dog owners are responsible and still
refuse to pick up after their dogs if
your dog fouls in a public area it's
your responsibility to ensure the mess
is picked up and properly disposed of
dog fouling is one of the top anti
social problems nationwide dog messes
unsightly on
and can spread disease-- or in extreme
cases cause blindness here are some tips
on how to be a responsible dog owner and
how not to annoy other amenity users
never let your dog walk too far from you
as this makes difficult to see where
they foul dogs will usually foul soon
after being let off the lead or out of
the car at the start of a walk so be
ready pay attention at all times to what
your dog is doing don't let a mobile
phone distract you always carry poo bags
and a torch for dark evenings dispose of
bags in a dog or litter bin or take it
home to dispose off in your household
bin not disposing of a poo bag correctly
is also a dog fouling and littering
offense keep the dog to the boundaries
of sports pitches if possible as even
after picking up residual deposits can
be left many complaints are received
from the sports players concerning
sports pitches always pick up from
maintained grass areas to report a
serious problem of dog fouling please
use our online form you can find it at
ww rh fu govt UK forward slash street
scene you can email customer services at
Rochford gov't UK telephone them 0170
2318 one double one if we receive a
complaint about dog fouling we will
inspect the site and arrange removal as
necessary fly-tipping can you help us
rochford district council is appealing
for help in tracking down fly tippers
who have been regularly dumping
distinctive manufacturing waste at
mucking haul road in barling Magna the
rubbish which appears to consist of
silvered cardboard stencils has been
left on two separate occasions in a
lay-by just past the wildlife park
portfolio holder for the environment
counselor Joe Macpherson said someone
out there knows exactly what this
material is and where it has come from
so we are appealing for any information
anyone can offer about the source or
possible sources the council says the
fly-tipping occurred at exactly the same
spot with exactly the same type of
rubbish within a two-week period however
rot your district council is keen to
help those responsible dispose of the
items responsibly and councillor
McPherson added we remind people that
there are fines that can be imposed but
we are keen to help anyone who has
material that needs to be removed and
disposed of we have one of the best
recycling teams in the country and can
advise on the legal and proper way to
remove unwanted manufacturing waste
without damaging the locality so again I
would ask that anyone posed with such a
challenge get in touch with the council
their cause and inquiries can be dealt
with confidentially and I have no doubt
we can help them take suitable action
the council always investigates reports
of fly-tipping if you see something
suspicious report it and to report a
street scene problem you can go online
at www k forward slash street scene you
can email customer services at Rochford
gov qk or you can ring 0170 2318 one
double one annual canvas for the
register of electors canvases are now
visiting the small number of households
which have not yet responded to the
household inquiry form canvases will
collect the details of everybody over
the age of 16 living in the property and
who is eligible to be registered to vote
all canvases carry photographic
identification if you've not received a
form or need help completing it please
call a helpline to speak to someone in
the electoral registration office
there's still time to respond before a
canvasser visits and remember you must
by law respond to the house whole
inquiry form and provide the information
asked for even if there aren't any
changes to the details pre-printed on
the form the system of registering to
vote changed in June 2014 and any new
names added to the form will receive a
separate application form to enable them
to register to vote you will need to
provide your date of birth and national
insurance number when you register the
quickest way to do this is online at www
k / register dash 2 dash vote you are
not automatically registered even if
another department within the council
holds your details for any other purpose
or you pay council tax you can only vote
in elections and referendums if your
name is on the register of electors your
credit rating can be affected if you're
not registered where you live for
further information phone the Electoral
Register helpline on 0 1 702 3181 h7 or
e-mail elections at Rochford gov dot uk'
please Like us rochford District Council
has launched its brand new page on
Facebook search for Rochford District
Council on WWF facebook.com and click
like the new facebook page is a great
way to keep up to date with what's going
on in the district and also share your
photos and feedback rochford District
Council's revised statement of licensing
policy licensing act 2003 including the
introduction of a cumulative impact
policy and the read-option statement of
licensing policy gambling act 2005 will
be available for consultation from the
17th of August this year until the 6th
of November 2015 these consultations may
be viewed on the council's website ww
rochford gov UK forward slash licensing
any comments on the contents of this
policy should be sent to Rochford
district council licensing unit 3 2 19
south street rockford essex the postcode
SS 41 b w or you could email licensing
at Rochford dot-gov dot uk' wild woods
an autumn fruits this is a great time of
year for exploring the many woods and
open spaces Rochford has to offer the
changing season brings with it plenty of
opportunities to watch nature's
theatrical show in action a garden seat
which was cut from another tree stump
has weathered and is now a haven of
insects and bugs with new shoots growing
through and up the trunk it looks as
though the chair has been there forever
mushrooms are popping up in abundance
including the corker that is growing on
a tree stump at the council garden in
rochford more palatable fruit can be
found with brambles Blackthorn's
elderberries slows and chestnuts the
idea of going out into the woods to
forage for food has become extremely
popular it helps children better
understand the natural food to table
chain is about as fresh as you can
possibly get and saves money meanwhile
the swallows and Swift's I leave in the
UK for the winter but the Red Wings and
field fairs arrive offering plenty for
bird spotters young and old at wallasey
island and the web site visit woods all
UK has an excellent site packed full of
activities for all generations there's a
fungus Potter sheet that can be
downloaded for an afternoon mushroom
spotting and a series of recipes based
on foraging fifty shades of P Rochford
District Council is working with the CCG
Nestor and partner organizations on a
100 day challenge to reduce unplanned
hospital admissions one key factor
causing many hospital admissions is
dehydration which may show itself in
various ways such as dizziness weakness
palpitations falling confusion and fever
simply drinking more water can reduce
the risk of dehydration as well as
eating fruit or even jelly did you
realize that in August last year the
majority of unplanned hospital
admissions that's a and E admissions
visits or stays could be directly linked
to poor hydration do you think you're
drinking enough next time you have a way
look and see a good color is very pale
light yellow and then the spectrum goes
through fair dehydration very dehydrated
and then extreme dehydration by which
time the color is dark orange home not
hospital service launched local health
partners are working together to
introduce a brand new way of delivering
care to residents in Castle Point and
Rochford with the ultimate aim of
keeping our most vulnerable people well
and in their own homes as long as
possible the new care coordination
service which begins from 1st of
September 2015 is unique because it aims
to reach those at high risk of
deterioration before they need urgent
use of local health and care services
working in partnership with GP practices
the new service will identify those
patients whose health they deem to be at
risk of decline predominantly the frail
elderly and those with long-term
conditions for the first time ever there
will be a unique team of professionals
and voluntary sector support services
operating in partnership in each
locality in Castle Point and Rochford
the team will assess individuals at
highest risk of health and care decline
and put care plans in place that aim to
prevent their deterioration and maintain
their health and well-being as long as
possible in their own home local health
partners held an event in rayleigh to
help educate parents and carers about
common childhood illnesses the event
attended by over 50 local parents and
carers of young children provided in
Nation about what to do what to look out
for and where to go Tim's ambulance also
gave a first aid demonstration using
props to show how to help a child who is
choking or needs to be resuscitated a
local GP dr. Luke white Singh from oddly
Mills GP practice in rayleigh hosted the
event and gave advice on the most
appropriate health services available to
parents and carers in various
circumstances dr. Luke whiting said when
a child is ill getting the right care is
a priority we've had some really
positive feedback about the event I'm
glad that we've been able to explode
some common myths and help local parents
feel more in control there are lots of
local services that can help when a
child is unwell people told us they'd
never think of asking advice from us are
a pharmacist for instance there was also
a lot of skepticism about the NHS 111
service to which is a great option if a
parent is worried and they want a
clinical point of view all those that
attended the event were given a goodie
bag that included lots of useful
information including a new guide to
common childhood illnesses the
user-friendly guide sets out a range of
conditions and explains the symptoms
what you can do and what to look for due
to the success of the event a similar
event is being planned and more
information will follow soon if you'd
like to obtain a copy of the guide
please contact her 1268 464 508 or email
cpr dot c c g at NHS dot net work to
reduce the risk of flooding in the roger
district continues to progress as
Rochford District Council carries out a
number of drainage improvement schemes
to ensure that areas prone to surface
water flooding are less vulnerable to
extreme weather conditions the works
which were organized by rocchio district
councils surface water flood forum
include a new day
to the rear of properties in blower
closed Raley to protect the properties
from surface water flooding which has
occurred in the past during prolonged
and intense rainfall clearance of
overhanging vegetation in Noble's green
ditch adjacent to bran field roast East
in rayleigh to improve drainage
improvements to grow would stitch
including installing culverts beneath
footpaths to improve drainage and reduce
the risk of flooding to residential
properties opposite the woods these
works are in addition to new tide valves
which were recently fitted in raw earth
Brook to prevent excess water flowing
back into land drainage ditches and many
other projects carried out by the
District Council and our partner
organizations roles of the different
agencies in flash flooding the Met
Office will give warnings if they expect
exceptional rainfall these are
extensively circulated through the media
via weather forecasts if the rain is
likely to lead to flooding related to
rivers the Environment Agency will issue
warnings as well as general warnings the
flood line service will inform
individual householders they know may be
at risk if they have registered for text
alerts the Environment Agency
responsibility extends to other critical
ordinary water courses which include
many of the main streams and some main
ditches most stitches are the
responsibility of the landowner Essex
County Council is the lead local flood
authority and has a role in overseeing
the management of local flood risk
including ground water flooding caused
when heavy or prolonged rainfall makes
the ground water table rise above its
normal level surface water or rainfall
runoff this is flows from or over
surfaces such as roads roofs and patios
that cannot easily absorb water ordinary
water courses streams and ditches these
are channels which cannot contain large
volumes of surface water runoff during
or after heavy rain Anglia water are
responsible for the removal of waste
water via the sewerage system sandbags
have a limited effect in protecting
properties during
flash flooding as they need to be stored
on the premises in advance of the event
sandbags can be obtained from commercial
outlets and sand purchased from builders
merchants the emergency services will
respond in the best way they can to
protect life during an incident flooding
on the roads is the responsibility of
essex highways where people have to
leave their properties the
responsibility for rehousing social
housing tenants lies with the relevant
housing association those in private
homes will need to make their own
arrangements but would look to their
insurance companies to assist there may
be cases where people become homeless in
which case they would be helped by
Rochford district council where large
numbers of people have been evacuated
rochford district council will use its
emergency arrangements to provide
temporary accommodation and care Roger
in District Council will work with its
residents during the recovery phase to
provide appropriate services for example
the removal of flood contaminated
carpets and furniture for information on
severe wet weather warnings www Met
Office garvey UK and the telephone
number o 870 900 oh one hundred
contamination recycle right if in doubt
check it out at Rochford dot-gov dot uk'
/recycling now here are a few statements
and questions from residents with
answers from one of the recycling
officers a resident said if I'm unsure
of whether an item can be recycled I put
it in the recycling bin anyway as it
probably gets recycled the officer had
this to say this is not true it's very
important to ensure that you only put
correct recyclable items into your grey
recyclables bin items that cannot be
recycled such as food waste and nappies
can contaminate whole lorry loads of
recyclable material
which can then no longer be recycled
another resident said I don't bother
rinsing up my recyclable items as they
get washed at the facility for recycling
anyway the officer had this to say this
is again not true any recyclable items
that have contained food all liquids
should be rinsed as any residue can
transfer on to other products such as
paper which is then no longer recyclable
a resident said my recycling bin wasn't
emptied this week and there was a red
label on the lid the officer had this to
say your bin contained wrong items
therefore we weren't able to empty it
please remove any wrong items and
present your bin on your next scheduled
collection day why can't I bag my
recycling in plastic sacks or carrier
bags officer said all recyclable items
should be placed into the recycling bin
loose we are unable to recycle plastic
sacks or plastic carrier bags due to the
nature of the plastic we are unable to
recycle or other plastic films such as
cling film sweet and biscuit wrappers
and crisp packets plastic carrier bag
should be reused where possible but may
also be recycled at some large
supermarkets a resident asked what would
happen if I continued to contaminate my
recycling bins the officer replied we
try to educate residents to recycle
correctly by carrying out visits and
sending letters however if contamination
continues bins can be removed and
residents are left with only their
non-recyclables bin for all their waste
and now here's some important
information about collection day itself
bins
be presented at the boundary of your
property by 7am on your sheduled
collection day if your bins are not
presented correctly and by correctly we
mean with the handles of the bins facing
outwards onto the road so that the
recycling people can move them quickly
they will not be emptied and we will be
unable to return to collect them for
full collection day information please
visit www k /recycling fusion lifestyle
invest over a hundred and forty thousand
pounds rochford District Council and
fusion lifestyle have officially opened
their brand new artificial pitches at
clements hall and rayleigh leisure
centres the pitch is funded by fusion
lifestyle are designed for football
tennis and rugby and will also be used
for fusions boot camps they are now
available for existing and new clubs and
groups to use as part of the centre's
program development there are plans for
sports courses leagues and competitions
which will add to the centre's overall
activity programs limits or leisure
center has a new 3g or third-generation
pitch which is a surface created by
using synthetic fibers and rubbers made
to look like real grass unlike some
artificial pitches 3g does not contain
sand therefore is much less likely to
cause friction burns to the skin due to
the very latest technology the 3g pitch
offers a maximum comfort underfoot
exceptional ball bounce ball roll and
good ball control the two new pictures
at Raley Leisure Centre are more
conventional and we provide an excellent
playing surface for all team sports Tony
House infusions divisional business
business manager for Rochford said we're
delighted to be launching these new
pictures now the work has been completed
at Raley and clements for leisure
centres the versatile nature of the
pitches means that they can be used all
year round for competitive team sports
family fun events or outdoor fitness we
look forward to making the most of this
new space and offering a broad range of
activity
for the community for further
information and/or to make a booking
inquiry please contact the center's
directly and Clements all leisure centre
is 017 0220 double 7 double 7 Railly
leisure centre is 0 1 2 6 8 6 5 4 5 10
or you can visit www.fcn hyphen
lifestyle com forward slash contracts
forward slash Rochford underscore
leisure family theater we're very
pleased to announce details for the
autumn 2015 to spring 2016 family
theater shows at the mill arts & Events
Center and we hope families will
continue to enjoy the fine range of
theater and puppetry on offer once again
we've put together a program featuring
familiar stories alongside original
tales presented to you by some of the
best small-scale theater companies from
across the UK on Sunday the eighth of
November at 2pm chicken-licken Sunday
the 17th of January at eleven o'clock
and two o'clock fly away Katy sunday the
twenty-first of februari at two o'clock
radio pirate sunday the twentieth of
March at 11 am-1 p.m. and 230 p.m.
handers hen all tickets are four pounds
and are on sale from our customer
services team on 0 1 702 3 18 19 1 this
program of family theater is arranged by
Rochford District Council and is
sponsored by fusion lifestyle all
children must be accompanied by an adult
details are correct at the time of print
but may be subject to change rochford
district and castle point health walks
walking is great for your health and
puts a spring in your step you can take
part in our free short walks near to
where you live at a pace that works for
you and with specially trained leaders
showing you the way it's a great way to
stretch your legs explore what's on your
doorstep and make new friends with in
rochford district Monday's 1045 am in
hullbridge the Maya two miles are the
walks you meet in the car park on the
corner of Ferry Road improves lane you
can get there on a number 20 bus
thursdays at 10 45 in hotly woods that's
between two point two and five miles
meet in the car park which is pay and
display and the entrance to that is next
to the bull you can get bus number seven
or eight for hockley and in both of
those places shorter 30 minute walks are
available castlepoint mondays 1030am
richmond hall benfleet that's two to
three miles and that's at the richmond
hall car park in benfleet and again
there is a shorter 30 minute walk
available at that venue wednesdays at
1030am Canvey Island seawall that walk
is 1.5 to 2 miles and you meet in the
lab worth car park the first and third
friday of every month at 1030am hadley
that walk is four miles long meet in
castle lane car park at the bottom of
castle lane for further information on
both schemes you could phone Rochford
district council on 0 1 702 31 8 121 or
check it out on the website WWE are a
govt UK Roger district disability sport
free weekly sessions in Baccio sitting
volleyball and table cricket are at
Stanbridge Memorial Hall the postcode is
SS for two AR for all ages and all
sessions are free of charge every Friday
232 5 p.m. participants welcome to
attend at any time throughout each
session whatcha is a tactical targets
port similar to balls or patang sitting
volleyball is similar to its indoor
counterpart with identical rules and
point systems players must be seated
at all times table cricket is played on
a table tennis table or similar with
side panels and sliding fielders a ball
launcher is waited for further
information please contact the
stanbridge Memorial Hall manager on 0 1
702 2585 66 or 0787 680 2420 you can
email memorial hall at stanbridge pc co
uk and if you require transportation for
any of the sessions please contact us so
we can discard walk discuss what
assistance we may be able to provide out
and about activities at Rochford library
the Wishing Well center every tuesday
from 945 to 1015 am stories and rhymes
for babies and toddlers the job club
every thursday from two till four get
help and advice with building your cv
and searching for work baby and toddler
group every friday from 9 30 to 10 a.m.
stories and rhymes for the up two fives
dial disability information and advice
this is the last tuesday of each month
1030am to 130 p.m. and computer training
we can help you to start using a
computer just to ask our staff for
details active life 50 plus exercise
session a fun exercise session for all
abilities this is at the hockley health
club Thursday's 130pm hawk well baptist
church hall fridays at nine thirty AM it
costs four pounds and you can contact
0170 2567 327 the forza karate club our
aim is to promote karate in its
traditional and sport form several
venues hawk well village hall main road
hawk well mondays five to six pm
rayleigh primary school love lane
rayleigh on fridays 3 30 to 4 30 p.m.
raley scout hall london road rayleigh
tuesdays 6 to 7 p.m. and on saturdays 10
to 11 a.m. the cost varies but the first
lesson is free contact 0740 108 double
oh seven eight info @ forza karate calm
and that's fo r z a karate calm and
there's a website WWF or Z karate calm
hockley art group all ability levels
welcome at this small and friendly group
they meet on Thursday afternoons the old
fire station in hotly and the contact is
Colin gammon 017 0220 4706 hockley jazz
records society listen to jazz music
bring your music and listen to others
programs this is on the third thursday
of each month between seven-thirty and
10pm it's at the hawk well village hall
and it's three pounds each night the
contact point is Ken mizen on 0 1 702
203 437 the mega centre youth club has
open youth club sessions including pool
sports games and arts special rates on
mega zone games are available during
youth club it's on mondays from 615 to
745 for school years 5 to 7 and on
tuesdays from seven till 9pm for school
years 8 plus it's free the contact
number 01 268 double 791 double zero you
could email Lucy dot Brown at mega
centre rayleigh or one word co uk and
the website is www megaupload UK there's
over 50 sports at the mega center as
well table tennis badminton and short
mat
Falls with a social group on mondays
wednesdays and thursdays from two to
four p.m. it costs four pounds per
person again the contact telephone
number is 0 1 2 6 8 double 791 double oh
the email for this is mega staff at mega
Center raledo UK and the website is the
same there's also mega soft play and
laser tag that soft play and laser tag
sessions well there are various sessions
and you'll need to check the website out
for those details however the soft play
is between one and six pounds depending
on the age laser tag is five pounds per
game per person Oh 1268 double 791
double-o mega stars at mega centre
rayleigh dot co uk www mega central e
dot co dot uk' the rayleigh library
writers group is a friendly group of
local writers and poets and they're
looking to recruit new members they meet
on the second thursday of each month
from 3 to 5 p.m. in room two upstairs in
the raid a library on the fourth
thursday of each month from 715 to 9 15
p.m. and you'll need to contact them for
details about that it costs a pound to
cover light refreshments and your
contacts are Jane on 0126 878 5427 or
Bob on 0126 878 double 496 you could
email him WR French at talktalk dot net
the roach art group caters for all
abilities at this friendly club good
lighting and facilities in a variety of
media they meet on Wednesday evenings
from 732 930 p.m. at st. Theresa's
church hall
chinden road the postcode for that is SS
41 r f and there are reasonable fees
that apply and you can get details if
you ask them and the person to ask is
Debbie Deb's 07 9077 14 double O 2 or
John 079 double 3263 930 WWE ROG group
WI XCOM the recycled teenagers forum is
a friendly and welcoming group providing
encouragement and support for 40-plus
that's not 40 plus in numbers but aged
40 plus people to access activities and
day trips at affordable prices they meet
on fridays from 11 until 11 45 a.m. in
the WI hall in rochford square there are
various prices and you'd need to contact
them for membership and trip information
you can do that on Oh 170 261 double 619
or oh double 79 220 double 724 you could
email recycled teenagers or one word at
live code UK and the website is WWE CEO
teenagers org UK during the autumn half
term there's fit for sport half term
activity camp a range of activities for
children aged 4 to 12 including
multi-sport team tastic super sports
splash session circle games fun zone and
much more Wednesday October the 28th
930am to 4 30 p.m. it costs 10 pounds
per child and you'll need to contact
0845 4 5 6 3 to double 3
jazz WWF it for sport coat UK and if
you'd like information about other
activities for half-term go to ww hfu
govt UK forward slash holiday activities
for information about everything that's
available this half term and now for
some events the rayleigh Lions firework
spectacular is an impressive fireworks
display choreographed to music plus
children's rides and food source it's on
saturday november the seventh the gates
open at five-thirty p.m. and the display
starts at seven-thirty it's in King
Georgie's playing field in rayleigh the
cost is seven pound per person and it's
free for children under 12 accompanied
by an adult tickets can be purchased in
advance for only six pound from rohnert
or Hatton's in rayleigh and also from
the rayleigh lines in the high street on
saturday october the 24th and 31st and
november seventh bell champs celts
centre fireworks display it's a great
fireworks display for all the family
including a giant bonfire this is on
saturday november the seventh the gates
open at 5pm the bonfire will be lit at
seven thirty and the child friendly
display is at six with the big bang
display at eight it's on at Bell champs
scout activity center holyoke leyline
hawk well it costs five pound for adults
and children are three pound fifty and
under threes go free you can contact
0170 256 2690 or email info at belle
shams which is b e l CH a mps UK and now
for some committee dates the development
committee meet on november the 19th the
review committee on november the third
and the executive committee on november
the fourth all meetings will take place
at the Civic sweet to hockley road rail
e SS 680 be and the meetings start at
seven thirty p.m. for more information
you can call the Member Services on 0 1
702 318 140
and finally a note for your diary
christmas lights switch-on events in
hockley this takes place on saturday
november the 21st room 326 p.m. rayleigh
is thursday november the 26th from 432
630pm hullbridge is saturday december
the fifth from three to six pm rochford
is sunday november the 29th and the time
is to be confirmed the winter edition of
roger district matters will have full
details of these and more events that
are happening around the district this
Christmas time rochford district matters
is designed and published by Rochford
District Council the telephone number
for the council is 0 1 702 546 366 this
recording has been produced by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castle point talking newspaper